all right scene 5 you're on deck skimmer
on a wad um hi everyone we're Team 5
where kure overs we're gonna do a little
role-playing for you today um okay class
today we're going to be learning about
Romeo and Juliet a timeless classic of
two star-crossed lovers it's gonna be
awesome oh come on can you look at the
website EDM and jams what's Eddie jams
website full lessons from teachers all
over the world can you at least look at
it before we start I will look at ed
jams did you wow this is a really cool
website there's lots of resources on
here for Romeo and Juliet I could have
my students do a rap battle that's
gotten lots of boats and stars from
other teachers or maybe my students
would really like to make a puppet show
oh that would be so cute oh and for all
my science nerds they could do
scientific inquiry of ineffective
poisons I wonder what that entails I
know let's make Romeo and Juliet the
musical that's perfect for my students
sing and I'll film and create a remix of
those Romeo and Juliet resources we saw
on exams and then we'll post it so other
teachers and schools could use our ideas
alright so ed gem is an education
revolution so it'll be an online
platform where teachers students
administrators and researchers can share
best practices this empowers teachers to
mix and match what works elsewhere all
the while adapting to what works in
their local context and then they can
mix remix post it back share it and get
feedback so this creates fun and
engaging classes that are great and for
both the students and the teachers so
forget the factory this is education as
a jam session
thank you guys so much great uh can we
have teen 6 on deck so how is this
different from all the other lesson
planning websites that are out there
already so I think the idea is to just
have it more fun because the thing is
like we were a lot of people talk about
making things that are fun and engaging
for students how about it making it fun
and engaging for teachers so that's the
idea with like mix and match and extend
it just not from lesson plans but also
to assessment tools to delivery methods
and also have teachers and students
engaged in the process and we think with
this idea of remix Inge that you see a
lesson you're inspired you create
something new with your students and
then you post that back up and we'd have
to have curators who are paying
attention and kind of monitoring what's
added but that you're adding your own
content and creating an even larger
repository of content that other
teachers and students could be inspired
by as well you're actually going to do
the evaluation of which you're the best
because other lesson planning sites have
had a lot of issues with a lot of junk
and getting to the best stuff right so I
think that's a big concern of ours that
curation part and that would take a lot
of human capital and manpower to go
through that we also want to create a
voting system so you know we had the
stars up there and so teachers and
students that are using these sources
could vote and say like this worked
really well or this didn't work so well
I think researchers are also really
valuable resource and partners in this
process so our major stakeholders are
not just teachers students parents but
there are also industry people
administrators and researchers and so I
think that will help how do you involve
industry so I mean we are trying to have
these engaged methods so it can be
through field trips it can be through a
project-based learning it can be through
like arts or music since I web sorry
yeah so these methods are posted on the
web and so teachers around the world
they kind of come up with their own
methods or maybe they come up with their
own remix version and they post it
online and so this is just a platform
that's online that's accessible
everyone and so that's where we have
researchers and industry as well okay
thank you thank you so much